wow
this one's a winner
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by David Blaine he's
known the world over for his street
magic and endurance stunts that include
everything from being buried alive for
seven days to encasing himself in a
block of ice to holding his breath
underwater for 17 minutes he also has a
pair of high profile projects on the way
with his documentary Adventure series
beyond belief with David Blaine coming
soon to Disney Plus in his sixth show
Vegas residency with dates through the
remainder of the Year David Blaine
welcome to the show wow thank you for
having me thank you I'm so excited to be
here by the way I'm very excited to have
you I know that you're someone who can
push themselves but how how are you
around spicy food I don't know how I'm
gonna do with them during this but that
is my thing but um I'll tell you so just
to give you an idea of how much I love
Hot Wings my when I premiered my show
which was the only premiere of a show I
did it for real or magic they wanted to
go do it in a big place with the big
movie screen so everybody could see it
you know and I said no no no
we have to Premiere at blondies at the
premieres in a buffalo wing Joy a Sport
Bar Buffalo joint up Uptown in New York
so and nobody could hear the show but I
was happy because I could eat all the
wings
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so this first one is the classic chili
Maple Edition here
oh great
very nice
Maple first time trying this one hidden
yeah it's great
foreign
building a big stage magic act in Vegas
I'm curious if this quote from David
Copperfield Rings true to you it takes
500 shows to get a trick right and more
than a thousand to make it feel good
that was one of the things that amazed
me about David was I went to see him
after a show and it was Saturday and it
was midnight and and they were all so
exhausted and
um and his partner Chris says oh we've
we've been here since 10 A.M
we've done three shows
like three shows in a day because like
my show has to be like once a month or
twice a month Max I said wow like how
many shows are you doing every day he
said well we do three on Saturdays two
on every other day guess how many per
year 300 more 400 500 no 600 650 shows
that go whoa like David like that's
crazy what are you doing and he says
well it takes me about 500 to get a new
trick right so that's the beginning of
starting to understand a new trick and I
went oh I got it bingo so yeah I love
that mentality and I agree and I think
all of my magician friends it's like a
the ones that I love are just it's com
it's a compulsion it's all they think
[Music]
it's great yeah a little Scotch bonnet
tropical action in there right
when it comes to your obsession with
magic I've heard you recount multiple
origin stories much like the Joker
explaining how he got his scars who is
lewd Tannen and can you describe to me a
typical day for a 10 year old at Tana I
can't tell you about that that's funny
but I'm not gonna tell you about the
camp I've been talking about going to
tannins
um
back then the store was like this Darkly
lit shop with all of these glass cases
and the glass cases had all these
objects that you would die to have so
I'd stare at these things and just dream
of like oh my God what could be done
with all those things but then in the
back room like this little side area but
not in the store if you were lucky
the best guys in the world would just be
hanging out there and so I'd sit there
and they would like blow my mind on stop
luckily by the way as a kid I only did
Magic to my mother and her friends
because if I did other kids they're a
tough audience they're gonna be like hey
you're weird you know yeah you suck so I
did all the magic to to my mother and
her friends and I thought I was good
because of their reactions and then I
just wanted to keep learning new things
to you know make make her amazed or
whatever
foreign
so this is the first shoot of the new
season
it's my first time trying the hot sauces
Pico Rico
I just made my way into Mount Rushmore
I I hate to say this but I kind of love
all of them so far
delicious lineup
so your name is synonymous with
death-defying Larger than Life
spectacles and to watch them from
outside they look like just such a pure
stress test and human concentration and
misery but is there one that you
describe as being like the most fun
Ascension to me
that was the most one but but that's
because it was with my daughter so that
I worked out the hard part of it before
she came to make it fun but I have to
say all of them are so fun I think it's
similar to this like I think it's like
so it's like you go in and you're like
you're going up a mountain really hard
but like you're so excited about it and
yeah you take a couple of shots
obviously but but it's it's it's the
like everybody says you know it's not
like getting to the end it's like that
whole process so yeah that process that
learning curve is what keeps me excited
about life so you know so I can't so
they're all fun in a certain way well
that actually really uh resonates with
me because while you're saying that is
like that's exactly how I feel about
these kinds of shoots where they're all
kind of of their own journey and then
their own experience and then as much as
you can kind of figure out how things
are going to go there's lots of
variables that you can't always test for
and things always go kind of sideways
then you have to adapt to those things
and that's the stuff that I think is the
best it's like when you have to deal
with the unknown it's always amazing so
like on stage when you get like a
curveball it's like that's what that's
what separates I think like a magician
that's really comfortable to a magician
that's uncomfort and which makes one
seems great one doesn't the one that
seems great even though this guy might
be just as practiced with the moves the
one that seems great when performing is
when a curveball comes he's ready for it
he No Matter What scenario he's hit with
he can keep going and it's interesting
because the magic people don't know the
end result so since they don't know the
end it's not over until you say it's
over so you could be like struggling for
10 minutes but if the end is a monster I
like that whole you know the the not
working and then make it work
I like all these questions by the way oh
well thank you very much it's kind of
early on in the game you know absolutely
easy I have plenty I have plenty of time
to knock this thing off the tracks
[Music]
oh right
looking at your face I can tell it looks
like we're four for four so far yeah
there we go
so your new documentary series beyond
belief with David Blaine has been
described as a global Odyssey across
remote cultures each embedded with
unique histories and practices is there
a mystical tradition that you learned
along your travels that you thought was
most compelling or that more people
should know about
well basically when I was working on
learning how to
put a gallon of water in my stomach and
then spout it out
I saw a little video of a guy doing it
in Africa and we couldn't track him down
he wasn't a performer he lived in a mud
hut outside of Liberia by like four
hours so we spent five years trying to
find him or something like that and he
had the secret so I flew all the way
there
learn the secrets from them stayed there
for I think a week or something like
that practiced all day every day and
then finally I got a little water spout
which means basically you put a gallon
of water in your stomach then you can
hold it for a few hours maybe you can
spout it out like a stream
I still haven't mastered but I was
trying it over and over trying to get
better and better and a good friend of
mine calls me up and says his name is
Dirk he says um
you know that thing that you put on your
show where you spout the water I think I
can do that
and he comes over and he comes in my
bathroom drinks a gallon of water and
goes
and he does it better than any magician
in history so I spent years traveled the
world and the guy that could do it lives
next door like two blocks away
um
yeah I love it
I I think I prefer that not as oily but
it's still great yeah first time with
the oil-based sauce it's still great
though thumbs up thumbs up still good
yeah all right Dave we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram we're doing a deep dive in our
guests and scramble interesting pictures
that need more context but for you we
have a theme called what went wrong and
we're gonna start from 2006 drowned
alive where you spent a week inside a
glass sphere filled with water what
didn't go wrong
first of all before I stepped in to the
water tank all of a sudden they said oh
you don't have insurance you need
insurance to get in the tank and all of
a sudden I'm supposed to start the stunt
we didn't have the right insurance for
Lincoln Center so it's like oh so then
we're you know going crazy trying to get
the right of course you need all that
stuff but it was just one of those
things that was overlooked
um
then we go in and the hands and the feet
we didn't understand how that would
become so painful like a pain that is
crazy I remember seeing the pictures of
your hands and then
the breath hold the big thing my whole
goal was I wanted to go obviously to the
record which was 908 and I think I got
to 708 and I started convulsing my best
friend happened to be in the front and
he'll stop it and they all jumped in and
pulled me up but I felt like I could
have kept pushing you know for like
another 40 seconds or something like
that it's like anyways so yeah there's a
lot of things that went crazy
from April 1999. this afternoon live we
spent seven days and nights in a
Plexiglas coffin this one was the
biggest mistake it was the easiest one
in in retrospect but
my friend Bill safe guy said um you
should have something before you go in
so it gave me like uh it was called a
mango bomb it was a mango juice
and I couldn't use a bathroom in there
obviously other than number one so the
whole week I had to hold the balance so
painful so difficult
all right one more for you this is from
September 2020 Ascension where you sort
almost 25 000 feet in the year while
holding on to dozens of weather balloons
part of my plan was to go higher than
anything on Earth which is Mount Everest
29 072 feet and um we stopped at 25 000
but they they were remote popping this
because I think they felt that I was
starting to um become a little hypoxic
up there so I think there I keep I'm up
there trying to go higher and I hear
and I'm something not going up anymore
but it was perfect because nothing
happened nothing went wrong so it was
the ideal amazing scenario nothing is
gone wrong so far in the hot sauce
lineup are you ready to move on here to
the back half sure all right so this one
turmeric bomb here and the six oh I love
turmeric
[Music]
yeah that one is hotter yeah
some magic historian Jim steinmeyer he
argues that the biggest problem with
magic in the internet age is that it's
damaged the skill of learning through
asking what are your thoughts on YouTube
and the effects of social media in
General on Magic as an art form over the
years well first of all it's amazing
that everybody now has access to see the
great stuff and I want to see kids like
the good stuff as a kid when I want to
see the best stuff as a kid I'd have to
go to the museum of broadcasting I need
to have to go through an archive because
there was no way to dig stuff up so it
is amazing that you can study see and
learn from all the greats
the disadvantage is what you're saying
it's like people like to copy so when
they see it and they don't become when
you read a book and learned a routine
you kind of processed it and you figured
out your own presentation of it and I
think that's the best way to get your
own character and your own learning
curve but I think he's right about that
that there is a side of it that is like
oh well it's so accessible and then the
secrets are all given away but the
secrets are often number one inaccurate
or the wrong method you know I think the
good stuff is still hard to find
so this next one has kind of a fun name
Cosmic disco here in the seven spot it's
a party we'll see
[Music]
wow this one's great
taste wise this is like amazing
now this one's amazing this is so far
this is my favorite it's no seriously
because it's hot as [ __ ] I I respect it
right there
if I wasn't here right now with all the
cameras I'd be getting these down to the
bones by the way
well I've had people come up to make
restaurants and say you eat like a pig
well here Open Season Let it Fly however
you want however you want David Blaine
dimex and scientists they've used you as
a case study on the limits of The Human
Condition do those findings do they
demystify The Human Condition for you or
is it the opposite no it's the opposite
I think that's what I think is amazing
about the life and humanity and
everything is that we're able to do
things that we just it's like you can
keep
dreaming up or coming up with things and
we're able to achieve them I love when I
fail because it just gives me a chance
to try harder to become better
all right so this next Wing is the bomb
Beyond Insanity we always go out with
the old in with the new on each new
season right except for this one that
stood the test of time because it's just
that brutal
are you ready to move on yeah all right
so whoa going right in
wow
foreign
wow
this one's still my favorite yeah I
don't think that this one is still my
favorite yeah
this one is just
but here's where I'm kind of diving into
your mind a little bit because I'm
wondering
do you have like an especially strong
hot sauce tolerance or is your ability
to kind of like concentrate
compartmentalize pain Focus through
things do you think that's giving you an
edge here in this kind of uh in this
kind of setting
[Music]
um
I think I just like mentally prepare
myself or something like that yeah I'm
ready for whatever
hold on one sec
so
when you were a teenager performing at
Posh restaurants for diners what was
like the number one guaranteed crowd
pleaser kind of trick in that setting
well let me interrupt you on a thought
sure so there's a magician named Garrett
Thomas
and he's incredible
and he knows how to walk up to you and
Destroy right away and the reason why is
because he works in Buffalo at a buffalo
wing joint so he has to get your
attention over at loud screens sport of
beds people eating wigs so it depends
you want something short Visual and
strong for me it's usually cards and
then once they're oh wow this is
interesting because there's some strange
weirdos standing over me trying to do
magical I'm eating and then when you
have them engaged then you can start to
do the stuff that like that you're
passionate about
you and me are probably similar in that
we've seen some of the craziest physical
reactions face to face with some of the
biggest stars in the world you know
if we took your reactions and put them
to my card tricks I'd have like a whole
new brand of magic yeah amazing I need
to pour like hot sauce on the cards take
a card not lick it Dave let's think to
show up in your car and lick it let's
take this show on the road no it doesn't
matter look ah gorgeous
[Music]
we can move on here now to number nine
if you're ready I would love to it is
called unique garlic from smoking Ed
Curry
[Music]
oh yeah
wow yeah
this one
wow
this one's a winner
wow yeah
this is from
pucker butt yeah I get it
um
but this one's delicious this is the
first one I'm like getting like a whoa
oh yeah like that butt yeah wow but
you're liking the taste I love it I know
I can tell this one's incredible because
it also gives you that Rush yeah I got
that rush I got a head high right now
David I gotta have that was nice yeah
is someone who's done nine Prime Time
magic specials what would you say was
like the goofiest creative note or
suggestion you've ever gotten from a TV
executive
what am I
one of my favorite
um reactions to a trick was uh I made it
quarter disappear off of a boy's hand in
Barstow and his reaction he just looked
at it and went
cool and I was in love with this kid I
was like oh my God this is the coolest
reaction ever like he was so it's like
what I did when I'm doing magic I give
it time and I'm bizarre like that was
everything and I showed it to everybody
so excited and they're like that's not
that doesn't work that's not good TV and
I was like but look like look how
amazing he is and I fought it's like I'm
airing that it was my first show by the
way so I didn't have like I was fighting
yeah and everybody loved it
cool
that was like one of my favorite TV
moments I was that was like the one that
I loved the most I had to fight for the
hardest ironically
[Music]
you don't have to if you don't want to
but as a Showman
whoa I'm gonna do it up I gotta
I gotta meet it I gotta meet it I have
to meet the opportunity
showman at heart over here so this is
the final one this is the final one
[Music]
it's good yeah
of course it's really good of course wow
David we gotta have you as the premiere
every season you know just have you come
in and
make sure that we got the right sauces
all right so David we've taken on the
wings of death and now the rest of the
show to me is kind of a mystery I don't
know anything that's about to happen all
I know is we are to clear the sauces
right Dom that's all I know so we'll
clear the sauces from the table
foreign
[Music]
I brought
um a picture
of something
okay uh actually I'll hold it this way
okay Carolina Reapers that's what that
looks like yeah it's cool right yeah
I've eaten those a couple of times I
want to stay as far away from those as
possible
see if you see how they just look like
they start to go yeah
um yeah
let me open up the case because these
you don't want to mess with
so see um
see like here
we actually have a
[Music]
these are special from smoking Ed
directly my favorite footage is you and
Klaus
yes yeah down in the basement of Jimmy's
eating Reapers yes that clip is amazing
so yeah so a little gift from smoking Ed
I think you know these well I know them
too well and will you just I mean I'll
show you all the cards are different
mix them up just yeah perfect
that's good we'll go face up so
can you pull pull some pull some halfway
up also which which one did you want
that or that which did you mean that one
yep not this one not or this one this
one or did you want that one this one
the king the suicidal King yes
that's funny
um okay so we'll use your the suicidal
King so look I just give it a little
actually can you pull the pull the piece
for me yeah
[Music]
not as good as the wings
[Music]
let's go yeah it appears to be gone
you choose one for me and one for you
all right I'll have this one you can
have that one are you sure no no I'm
gonna swap them do you want to change
back yep
do you want to change the goat no I'm
set you're sad yeah yeah
took a knife from your uh your kitchen
and
you
cut the pepper that you chose in half
[Music]
yeah and open it pull it open
see inside see there's a card
yeah
yeah you see that little piece of the
card
is the king of hearts in here put it put
it right here let's put it right next to
here
you can see that this is actually the
exact piece
it goes right there
[Music]
this is a piece yeah this is
ah
amazing
I don't my brain is frazzled right now
this was this is a smoking a pepper
and uh here comes the part that I'm most
excited about that I've never done by
the way all right are you ready
I don't know
you never are ready you never are right
Cheers Cheers grip it and rip it
oh I already know what this is gonna be
like David Blaine this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
foreign
wow
wow
[Music]
incredible
wow
it's pretty awesome
wow that was amazing yeah
oh so that's the hot ones experience
amazing yeah yeah
so
you've never eaten a Carolina Reaper
before this is my first time oh
what do you think amazing
smoking it is my hero he is he's all of
our hero and I was like how do because I
asked you guys I asked you guys to get
the pepper oh and then everybody said no
he's like whatever you know so then I
just figured out oh I'd call smoking ebb
and he's amazing before she comes
through yeah
oh this milkshake hits
uh no okay
thank you so much for watching today's
video and hot ones fans I have a very
exciting announcement the the hot ones
Shake Shack collab is finally here the
hot ones cheese fries the hot ones
Burger the hot ones chicken all made
with a shack sauce that includes hot
ones the classic along with the last dab
it's very spicy it's very delicious and
it's available for a limited time now
through the end of the year at Shake
Shacks Nationwide and via the Shake
Shack app be careful around your eyes
and don't forget to order a milkshake
[Music]